[Music]
on this thursday night political
upheaval in alberta premier jason kenney
forced out of the party he united the
healing process for our party can begin
only when he's gone
his party now divided plus the
implications federally no access huawei
technology blocked from canada's 5g
network
secret training exclusive access to the
canadian combat veterans training
ukrainian civilians to take on russian
forces we can do a lot more by training
the guys here than just going to the
front suspected cases of monkey pox in
canada what we know and don't know about
the virus and the royals fly north
reconciliation and climate change take
center stage on their tour
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
after a three-year long review the
federal government has finally made a
decision on huawei it has banned the
chinese telecom giant from installing
its technology in canada's 5g network
along with a state-owned zte technology
another chinese company their technology
is also banned from the existing 4g
network and anything installed must be
removed it brings canada in line with
allies like the united states
let me be very clear
we will always protect the safety and
security of canadians and will take any
actions necessary to safeguard
our telecommunication infrastructure
our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stevenson is with me mercedes not a huge
surprise but it sure has taken a long
time to get here
it's taken years donna and the
government wouldn't say if there was any
new national security revelations that
had set this apart but behind the scenes
what people say is this was all about
waiting for the two michaels to be
released from china there was deep
concern about their well-being and
putting a ban on huawei while they were
still in a chinese prison that of course
is resolved now and so the feeling is
that the government is ready to move
forward the reality is many telecoms in
canada have developed 5g technology
without this assuming it was eventually
de facto banned by not acting there was
concerns that the chinese government
could use national security laws to hack
into canadian systems through that and
as well the canadian government didn't
want to be seen uh to be approving of
huawei after their direct involvement in
what happened between mong wang zhou and
the two michaels there's questions now
about what retaliation might look like
including for canadians who are in china
or potential cyber attacks here in
canada as for telecoms who have chosen
to install the technology despite the
risk the canadian government says that
they are not going to be reimbursing
them in any way financially for their
decisions and this may be the change of
direction for the trudeau government
that prime minister trudeau first
indicated in his interview with us at
christmas donna saying that democracies
need to band together and stop being
played off against each other on
economics by china
all right mercedes stevenson in ottawa
thanks now to the political upheaval in
alberta last night premier jason kenney
said he was quitting as leader of the
united conservative party today after a
six-hour caucus meeting he said not
quite yet kenny's leadership challenged
from within his own caucus collapsed
last night 51.4 percent of party members
voted to keep him and kenny said
wednesday that that is not adequate
support to continue as leader
then there's today tom vernon is outside
the building in calgary where that
caucus meeting just wrapped up tom turns
out kenny's not leaving until the party
finds a new leader yet almost half the
membership just voted to get rid of him
so do you know what happened in that
caucus meeting
it was a long one i mean it was
originally scheduled to last two hours
it went more than six hours and we got a
statement just a short time ago that
after much debate inside a vigorous
discussion and debate about the future
of the party that they have decided that
they must remain united and focus on the
best interests of albertans and be
committed to doing the job that
albertans elected us to do
and in doing so jason kenny will remain
premier until a new leader is elected
now this would have been a vigorous
debate coming into the meeting this
morning we spoke with brian gene who
came back to politics specifically to
remove jason kenney as leader and he's
made it no bones about it that jason
kenny must step down and there must be
an interim leader for this party to
begin to move forward for the divisions
inside the party to begin to heal we
heard other mla say the same sort of
thing but apparently the premier had
enough votes in caucus to remain in
place what we don't know is when the
leadership election will be launched and
when that new leader will be elected so
we don't have a timeline at this point
do we know if kenny has ruled himself
out of running for the leadership a
second time could he conceivably do that
i
it'd be tough to to believe but i mean
the the constitution the party
constitution says an interim leader
cannot run for the leadership of the
united conservative party i guess
technically premier jason kenny is not
the interim leader he remains the leader
of the party now he did tweet out the
letter that he sent to the party saying
that he will remain on until a new
leader is elected and he will resign
once that new leader has been selected
so i don't know if he would resign to be
named the leader again if he ran in this
again but we have not gotten a clear
answer from him yet interesting times
donna interesting time stranger things
alright
tom vernon in calgary tonight thank you
the biggest turmoil is inside alberta
but the turmoil of jason kenney and the
fracture in the conservative party have
implications on the federal scene as
well our chief political correspondent
david aiken is with me from ottawa david
well you know donna the ability to push
out a leader even a sitting premier
that's a feature not a bug for many
conservatives across the country it's
part of the grassroots heritage
stretching back to the reform party's
ideas of giving citizens recall power a
leader that falls out of favor with the
base had best watched their backs and
that is jason kenney that was aaron
o'toole that was andrew scheer and this
is a trend that did not escape the
notice of randy bosno he's a liberal and
he's the only member of justin trudeau's
cabinet from alberta
i'm sensing a disturbing trend in
conservative politics in in canada and
across the country mr kenny was pushed
out of his party because he wasn't
extreme enough
now some conservatives will object to
being called extreme but conservative
insiders tell me the lesson for leaders
of conservative parties everywhere is
clear you lose your job if you lose the
base but there's a danger for a leader
that focuses so much on the base they
forget about the broader electorate the
voters you need to win to win an
election indeed this is the defining
question of the federal leadership
contest win the base or expand the base
pierre pollierev or jean charae expect
kenny's resignation to become an issue
in the federal leadership contest donna
all right david aiken thank you
now to russia's war in ukraine u.s
president joe biden says finland and
sweden have the full total complete
backing from his country to join nato
finland and sweden
make nato stronger
not just because of the capacity of
their strong strong democracies
and a strong united nato
is the foundation of america's security
the leaders of finland and sweden join
biden at the white house the once
neutral nordic nations have formally
applied to join nato in response to
russia's invasion of ukraine they're
facing a challenge from turkey but the
white house expects that issue to be
resolved
over the past couple of months photos
have begun appearing on social media
from ukraine showing destroyed russian
military vehicles spray painted with the
word wolverines the peculiar calling
card has sparked international intrigue
over who is responsible for destroying
and tagging the russian tanks jeff
semple reports from ukraine where he got
exclusive access to a secretive group of
foreign volunteers
at a secret location in western ukraine
these ukrainian civilians are receiving
a specialized training course
they're learning to fight
like wolverines this is something new
and special i've never been part of
anything like this before
last month after russian forces suffered
a crushing defeat near ukraine's capital
residents surveying the damage came
across a peculiar site abandoned russian
military vehicles spray painted with the
word wolverines
the photos shared on social media
sparked international intrigue over who
was responsible
well now the secretive group is stepping
out of the shadows for the first time
granting global news exclusive access
inside their operation
we're going in loud and we're going in
fast
the wolverines are led by around 100
volunteers from 20 countries american
british and canadian combat veterans and
former special forces
here to fight the russians and train the
ukrainians because a lot of these guys
don't have any training this wolverine's
instructor is from bc the more people we
can train that's more people who can
help defend the country so we can do a
lot more by training the guys here than
just going to the front
over three months they provided this
week-long crash course to more than six
thousand ukrainians from soldiers to
civilians
i learned a lot literally a lot from the
guys this ukrainian one of the first to
be trained had no combat experience now
he's training others
how it was three months ago how i am now
is completely different level
besides learning how to clear an
abandoned building perform rescues and
operate an ak-47
the wolverines are also learning the
power
of a symbol
the wolverines shoulder patch is
inspired by a cold war classic
the fictional 1984 film red dawn about a
group of american teens who fight off a
soviet invasion of the united states all
while using their high school mascot's
name as a calling card before completing
their training the ukrainians are
required to watch the movie for
inspiration
and the guys absolutely love it it's a
clear
presentation
of how
young motivated people
not professional soldiers can step up
step up to the plate
and knock it out of the park the
wolverines and their ukrainian students
then head together to the front lines
armed with guns and cans of spray paint
to leave their mark
it's
something to inspire people people see
it
they know we're here they know that
they're not alone and it seems that
message is getting through
[Music]
a ukrainian pop star just released this
music video dedicated to the wolverines
meanwhile in central ukraine they took
down this soviet statue and replaced it
with a wolverines tagged tank
this was like a beacon of hope for our
guys it really was that the people are
getting it they see it they're out there
they love it but also this has an impact
on the psychology of the russians you
know to know that the world has united
against them
we're here
and he says they're here to stay until
the war
is won
jeff semple global news in western
ukraine
suspected cases of a rare virus in
canada coming up it could be monkey pox
why public health officials say not to
panic
in ontario two of the four leaders of
the province's major political parties
are sidelined with covid19 two weeks
before election day ontario ndp leader
andrea horvath and green party leader
mike shriner have both tested positive
both are not seriously ill they're
isolating but feeling well and plan to
continue campaigning remotely
pc leader doug ford and stephen del duca
of the ontario liberals tested negative
all four shared a small stage on monday
for a televised debate the election is
june second
we've no doubt heard about monkey pox by
now more countries around the world are
reporting potential cases of the rare
virus including canada cases are usually
confined to africa and researchers are
trying to figure out how widespread the
virus is jamie morocco explains what
monkey pox is and how it might have
traveled here
dr safa barcati has made a career of
studying rare tropical diseases and
until recently she had never even seen a
suspected case of monkey pox there was a
feeling of oh my god like are we really
seeing a case and you know there's
yeah we're
a little bit shocked but this week there
have been 17 possible cases of the
contagious virus reported to public
health officials in and around montreal
so far we have a few links of travel we
have this case particularly in the
united states one american man
recovering in hospital recently traveled
to canada the virus has also shown up in
clusters in the uk portugal sweden italy
and is being investigated in spain
unusual as it is rare to see the illness
outside of africa is this a new variant
of this virus that is more transmissible
human to human
or is it that this virus emerged into
conditions that were just right to allow
it to spread monkeypox spreads through
close contacts or even aerosols and is a
cousin of smallpox something most
canadians over 50 would be vaccinated
for symptoms can include fever headache
fatigue and swollen lymph nodes as well
as facial rashes and lesions we should
definitely see an increase of the number
of cases throughout the coming the
coming days that's for sure shifting the
priority to containment and contact
tracing jamie morocco global news
toronto
ahead how easy is it to smuggle illegal
handguns into canada
cross-border gun smuggling has long
played a role in the rise in gun
violence in canada last night we told
you how a single illegal handgun from
the u.s is linked to the unrelated
murders of two ontario teenagers how did
that gun get here in part two of our
global news investigation tracy tong
looks at how easy it is
if you're in for a long gun you have to
be 18 years of age you have to be a
resident of michigan you have to be a
citizen in the united states what about
handguns handguns you need to be 21
and we're going to execute some
paperwork to make sure that your gun
gets registered with the state of
michigan the paperwork involved in
buying a handgun in michigan involves a
form which asks if you're an american
citizen if you're the actual buyer of
the firearm if you're a convicted felon
and if you're not flagged in the fbi's
instant background check system the gun
is yours
how easy is it to lie on that form very
easy i have no i have no way of knowing
if you're being truthful or not people
are really good at duplicating
identification now fraudulently american
authorities call it lying and buying and
it can be even easier at gun shows the
rules are more relaxed for private
sellers who aren't officially making a
business out of buying and selling guns
i suppose if a citizen a citizen there's
no background check being conducted now
if i happen to know you're a felon
then it's illegal for me to transfer you
a gun but how would you know that
i wouldn't you'd have to tell me
straw purchasing is when someone buys a
handgun for someone else who is usually
ineligible to purchase it do i think
they understand what they're doing is
wrong yes i do do i think they
understand the carnage that they're
going to cause
i don't but i think unfortunately in the
end the money talks this is 580. yeah
what sells for a few hundred bucks in
the united states multiplies in value on
the canadian black market on the streets
in toronto these would go for about five
to seven thousand dollars i believe that
that's because you can't get them it's a
lucrative business
last year the canadian border services
agency seized more than eleven hundred
firearms and that is just a fraction of
the flow
even recently in november 56 firearms in
a bag in a trunk of a car and cross a
border
663 crime guns were recovered in the
city of toronto in 2020
about 85 percent police say are traced
back to the united states i brought
samples of the top 10 crime guns that
are seized in the province of ontario
the taurus pt 740 slim is the same kind
of gun used to kill ontario teenagers
jeremy cook and lee sent ross in 2015.
why would somebody opt for this one well
it's cool it's easy to use it's easy to
load and
inexpensive the ultimate price
paid in lives lost tracy tong global
news
and that price keeps going up in part
three tracy looks at who's bringing
these weapons into canada and whether
they'll face justice that's tomorrow on
global national and you can read more
about the story online on our website
globalnews.ca
global national
royalty goes north next what was on the
agenda as the future king met members of
the indigenous community
prince charles and his wife camilla have
landed in the northwest territories
received a warm welcome at the
yellowknives denny first nation
community of detta reconciliation and
climate change are taking center stage
during this last day of the royal visit
to mark the queen's platinum jubilee our
heather urex west is there tonight where
the royals have been meeting with
indigenous leaders
donna reconciliation has been a major
focus of the royals three-day whirlwind
canadian tour culminating with plenty of
opportunity here in the northwest
territories for the couple to listen and
learn
in our language we call it tuned
joe bailey loves to share his community
and his culture with visitors he
operates a tour company offering
northern adventures with opportunities
to better understand the indigenous
experience here
we do a tour down
fort province they have the first
residential school memorial there
and i bring guests and i talk about
residential and what happened
i cry every time as a memorial
as an intergenerational residential
school survivor bailey says it's
important for the royal family to at
least acknowledge the trauma of the past
who do we want to be
[Music]
a country
on a path of reconciliation
a country that listens
your royal highnesses we welcome you on
this path with us
at a reception at rito hall wednesday
night canada's first indigenous governor
general urged the royal couple to keep
learning while other indigenous leaders
including assembly of first nations
chief rosen archibald expressed the need
for an apology from the crown for the
pain caused by residential schools
in the spirit of reconciliation
community members joined the prince and
his wife thursday in the denny first
nation community of deda for the sacred
feeding the fire ceremony a traditional
way to seek guidance and offer thanks
we're so
honored for him to be here and be part
of it feeding the fire today it's pretty
great that we are the ones they chose to
come to and the ones they chose to talk
to
climate change and its impact on
canada's north was also a focus of the
royal visit the data ice road a critical
link between communities through the
winter has lately been open to the
public for only 90 days because of ice
integrity compared to more than 140 days
decades ago after the royals depart the
community will have something to
remember the royal visit by the platinum
jubilee garden in yellowknife will
feature many sacred indigenous plants
sage and sweetgrass as well as orange
flowers to remember the legacy of
residential schools heather urex west
global news indeda northwest territories
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen